there was this Irish bar that we would
go to a ton in Long Island uh down in
Port in Port Jeff and you know it was
literally a biker bar like it was just
an Irish biker bar that place where it's
like it's dark at 12 and there's people
hanging out in the bar and I this is how
young I was
um you know those little like pop shot
basketball kind of they had one of those
I was young enough where they put me
inside the cage on the other side of
where the balls go down and I would just
be free throwing from two feet out while
there's like you know it's your playpen
while your mom's drinking too
[__] play
back to this day do hack and play a joke
I'm telling you that's your pack and
play you got an eight month old
I'm telling you it's my Slumdog
Millionaire I never lose a pop shot to
this day dude it's like a muscle memory
I know the touch
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler